all right so let's go ahead and start
creating our react app
you can see that i'm here in a folder
called react web app where i've only got
a license and a readme so let's go ahead
and do an npm init to
set up this directory
and so now we have added our
package.json
if you don't already have it installed
we should install create react app it's
a easy way to create react applications
from facebook
once you have create react app installed
you can actually use create react app to
create a
new react application so let's go ahead
and do that
and we're calling this app my app
wonderful so once
uh that's done downloading and
installing you can see a bunch of
commands that create react app provides
first to get started and they tell us
exactly what we can do is to cd to my
app
and then
in my app you can see now if we open
this up we now have a my app folder
has its own node modules
has a bunch of code here
that we will explore in a moment so
let's actually go ahead and start up our
app
and see what that looks like
and here is the start of our
wonderful little application running on
localhost 3000 that's also pointed out
in the logs here
so the really wonderful thing about
create react app is not only does it
build
us an application that's ready to go and
ready to be modified it even comes with
a test that we can execute
if we look at package.json
we can see that if we run a
npm test command it's going to run
some tests and so what we can do is open
up a new tab here
and do npm
test
and that's going to execute
a unit test here
that we have an app.js and this test is
actually using a react testing library
but what you can see here is we have a
test
that will render the learn react link
here we use a method called render
and we are rendering our app component
and
next
you can see that we are using the screen
to get an element by text called learn
react and then finally we are expecting
that link element to be in the document
um this is a
just expect and to be in the document is
the react testing library uh assertion
that's fantastic because now we have a
unit test that's already ready for us
and it can run
regardless of whether our application is
up or not so if i close down our app
and then come back here and rerun the
tests
they will still continue to work because
they don't need a server
we are actually going to go ahead and
push this up into ci
so the easiest way to get started with
github actions is to come over here to
the actions tab in your github repo
making sure that you have one created
and then you can come and say a new
workflow
github actions will provide you some
suggested workflows and then notice it
notices that we are obviously using
node.js and so then it can recommend us
a potential workflow
this one right here looks fantastic so
let's go ahead and click it it already
comes with a bunch of steps that have
been configured for us
and the other nice thing about
creating your yaml file here is that you
also get a little ide that you can use
for example
you can see that if we don't do
something right like let's say we do
something like this the ui automatically
highlights anything that
may go wrong and so it says that we're
missing a runs on here and so then we
can do runs on
and then now it says that the value
cannot be null and then that's where you
supply the value
so this is what our
ci pipeline should look like and let's
go over it step by step by the way you
can see it's automatically gets created
in a dot github slash workflows folder
and then you give your file a name
i'm calling our ci pipeline ci you can
call it of course anything you want and
then at the very top i am setting three
environment variables
these environment variables
are the screener api key source username
and source access key they are coming
from
secrets
uh variable that is part of github
actions and then coming from the key
called screener api key here sauce
username and source access key so the
value from here is retrieved and stored
in the
environment variable on the left hand
side so where are these values coming
from let me show you that it's
very intuitive in github actions
you come to settings
scroll down to secrets you can see i
have three keys that have been created
here and inside of them they have the
corresponding values that will then be
set in here okay
next we are saying that we want this ci
to run on push requests and pull
requests whenever we do that to the
master bra main branch
next here we are defining the jobs that
we want to execute we're saying we're
going to run on ubuntu latest there are
multiple types of different kind of vms
available for you to execute on and i'm
going to be running on node version 14.
you can execute on
other node versions if you want of
course and then we are using the steps
a lot of these steps were previously
provided for us and i've made some
modifications to help you get started
faster with your ci pipeline so the very
first thing we want to do is install
dependencies
um and here we are doing exactly what we
were doing in our command line for our
application and so we would have done cd
my app right and then done a npm install
however i'm simply using mpmci which is
actually faster in github actions
because it ends up caching our
dependencies so this is the recommended
action to take in ci
next we're going to build the app right
this was just um seating to my app and
doing an npm run build to make sure we
have a production version because
whenever we do an npm start here
and our application comes up
here in localhost 3000
and we take a look at our uh react
developer tools we can see it's red and
it says this page is using the
development build of react which we
obviously don't want to use for
production we want to use the c uh we
want to use the production build and so
that's how you do with npm run build
next we're executing our component tests
after our app is built we simply do the
same thing by navigating to that
directory and running the tests exactly
as you saw before and then finally we
are starting up our application actually
starting the server by doing npm start
and then we're doing a wait on command
that will wait for the app to start up
for up to 60 seconds before erroring out
and we will expand this pipeline as we
expand our testing so
once it's ready
um the only reason i recommended to use
the uh ui was to help you with the
intellisense but ultimately the best way
to do it is to come to my app and then
make sure we're gonna add a uh
github
we're gonna do that github
slash workflows
oops
and then we're going to add a new file
here let's call it ci dot yaml
it will look exactly as i showed you
here i actually named it to ci2 so that
we can see
uh let's quit our tests
and do it and do a push
and once we do a push that should start
executing our ci pipeline let's come and
take a look at that
we'll see that i have this new branch
open so let's go ahead and do a pr with
this branch
i made one mistake here i should have
put github workflows in the very root
not inside of my app so what you'll see
is i moved that to the correct location
did another push and so now we have a ci
pipeline that started executing here's
the name called ci2 exactly the name
that we gave it in the gml file and it
did fail after nine seconds so let's go
ahead and take a look at exactly what
happened
so the air says that we can only install
packages with the package log json
or npm shrimp
json so
let's go ahead and fix that
in order to do that what we need to do
is
come to my app and do an npm install
which will create a package log.json
and then let's go ahead and add it
and we can watch our
ci rerun
here you can see we just committed 14
seconds ago here's a little yellow
circle that shows that rci pipeline is
running let's go ahead and take a look
at the details
wonderful so there is our ci pipeline
that is not only able to
build our app and start it up it's also
able to even run some component tests
against it
so if we take a look of where we are in
our testing journey
you can see based on this table that
we've actually got a pretty long way to
go before our app is fully tested it's a
really tiny app that we haven't even
made any functional changes to and so
far the only thing that we know about
this application without testing it
manually is that a url with the correct
text does exist in the dom of the
application
we've validated that with a component
test
which
came
with
our app create react app and we did that
using react testing library in jest
how about actually
knowing whether the url is correct right
it may
be there with the right text but does it
go to the right location so let's go
ahead and write up another test for that
the very first thing that we want to do
is make sure that we are running our
test suites here in
and then we can add a test that looks
like this where we say where that we're
testing that a url is correct rendering
our component as before getting our link
element as before however now we are
going to validate that the href of the
link element will contain
ultimateqa.com because that's
where we
want our url to navigate to and then
once we hit save watch this window in
the bottom right
it's going to execute
all of the tests in this file
here the first one passed which makes
sense but the second one failed the url
is correct um it's saying that we
expected
ultimateqa.com but we got react
js.org and that's because we need to
make an update to our application to go
to ultimateqa.com
so let's come here and go to app.js
and we will change the url
to ultimateqa.com
we're going to hit save
our tests are going to rerun and now
both of them have succeeded
also while we're here we
this linked text is no longer correct
because we're not going to learn react
instead we are going to learn testing
so let's put learn testing
and dev
and hit save
and
our tests both have failed and the
reason that they both have failed is we
can take a look at our logs and it's
saying that it's unable to find an
element with the text learn react um and
then it spits out the dom for us here
showing everything that it is visible
and of course this is the text that
exists however
the this exercise also showed us that
having
text as a check in our test is not
really a good strategy because we can
often change the text of our links and
so we can instead use a better strategy
such as supplying a data dash attribute
um and so here we can do a data dash
test id
and we can call it a learn
link
we'll
hit save here we'll come back to
app.test
and now instead of getting by text we
can get by id so let's go and do that
let's give this a run
and now everything passes because we are
getting our element by test id and of
course if we decide to change the text
our tests continue to work
let's go ahead and push this up into rci
here's our commit
and here is our check
we can
check on it back in a moment
so our ci pipeline has executed
successfully which is wonderful so let's
see where we are in our testing journey
so at this point we are we have now
tested that the url is correct
now how about making sure that our
application actually renders correctly
we can do a this test as well as making
sure that our application looks correct
on web and mobile using two different
technologies we're going to use
webdriver io and shift right by testing
our rendered application later in the
stage of the development cycle
and we're going to use visual snapshots
to check our application in different
resolutions in the browser to make sure
that our app is responsive and that it
looks correct on different types of
devices
and for that we are going to use
webdriver io
let's install webdriverio
let's configure web drive io
you're going to get a nice handy
menu that allows allows you to decide
what you're going to do so we're going
to execute on the cloud using sauce labs
yes
so this will be our username and this
will be our access key
no we don't want to do that which is the
default
once you've selected all the options
now you're going to wait for webdriver
io to install all the appropriate
packages
so once all the installation is done the
only other thing that you'll need to
install is the wdio sync service
and so once you have everything
installed this is what our package json
looks like everything that we added if
we look at the diff you can see we've
got a few w
d i o uh services
added
for our testing purposes
um webdriverio tests by default go to
test specs directory and in here i
created a visual.spec.js
file and in here we're going to have our
visual test
this visual test uses the standard
describe it format and then the commands
come from the browser object which is a
global object from web drive io we
navigate to a url
and then we execute two important
commands
first we do an init which will provide a
name for the app that we're testing so
we can say um my react app for example
and then the next one we're gonna do is
um a snapshot this is capturing a
snapshot of the page that we want to
test and so in this case it's our home
page uh and so we are calling it
home page
so the config file for web drive io
lives over here and
there's a lot going on in here but that
we can take a look at only the important
components so here i've created two
constants called visual options and
source options where i am
setting some api keys here i'm setting
the uh screener api key i am providing a
project name i'll show you how that
correlates to the actual
ui and then i'm saying to scroll stitch
screenshots to enable that to true so
that uh when my apps are pulled up the
entire page is scrolled and stitched
together
next i am enabling
a source connect which is an https proxy
that allows me a secure connection from
localhost into the cloud execution
environment for screener and sauce labs
this is telling us where the specs are
for our tests and then finally the most
important part of this i would say
is the configuration to run on multiple
different browsers and operating systems
so i'm running this on two of the most
popular browser resolutions the very
first one is
this one here
on this viewport size which is the most
popular desktop and running on windows
10 and chrome
and then the other
type of browser that we're running on is
mac os safari on this resolution which
is an iphone x viewport size and of
course we can have a lot more
resolutions here and what's going to
happen is
our visual spec is going to run on both
of these platforms at the same time
we can of course run it
we can run our tests using this command
here
but instead let's add a test script to
our package json
we can come here and add
and then ensuring that in a separate
terminal you have the application
actually running on localhost 3000
because it has to be up for us to do
end-to-end visual testing we can now run
our visual testing command
at this point we can see that it's
executing two specs and of course that's
our safari and chrome specs let's go
take a look at the screener ui to see
what's going on over there so we can see
that uh here is our new app dash two
that we started uh there are currently
tests running
the build has failed and the reason why
it failed is because we have two brand
new snapshots that we've never accepted
before what screener is currently
telling us is that hey i've got these
two snapshots
of
these resolutions of this page here of
the home page and i don't know whether
they are acceptable to you or not so we
can open each one up and take a look
does this look good to us and correct
yes it does we can come here and set
this as a baseline from this point
forward every single automated test will
validate against this version of the
baseline
and this is the bigger resolution here
and uh this one looks fantastic to us as
well let's go ahead and accept it
and so now from this point forward and
new executions will run against those
baselines let's also now add this visual
step to our ci pipeline and see that
execute
here we are back in rci yaml
we've added a brand new step our after
application has rendered to run visual
tests and performing the following
commands let's go ahead and check all
this into ci and see what happens
we've got a new commit here for adding
visual test and here is our ci pipeline
executing
so here's our pipeline after execution
we can see our visual tests have
executed successfully with a check mark
and if we scroll all the way down we can
see that two tests have passed
so the current version of our
application it's a little boring right
let's make it a little bit better and
actually see the power of visual testing
so we're going to replace this logo with
another logo
by coming into app.js
and we can see that up here at the top
we're pointing to an svg let's change
this svg and instead we're going to
point to
mia.jpg which is a
nice file that i've uploaded so let's
save that and watch our application
render and here is the cutest little dog
in the world her name is mia and of
course we can also even change
this link right here to be instead of
learn testing we can change it to
something else
we can say
learn testing
with nikolai
and mia
fantastic
our application rebuilt
and this is what it looks like
and we can even run our tests
to make sure that everything is working
as before our component tests
both of them working successfully
because remember we added that nice data
test id attribute and now we can check
in these changes and see what happens to
our visual test
here's our change
in github
let's
see what's going on
so now if we look at the screener ui we
can see that our new app 2
has two changes let's click take a look
and see exactly what happened
and so what screener shows is two visual
changes that have occurred a screener
uses a smart hybrid div meaning that it
analyzes the dom and element shifts um
and it identifies exactly the two
elements that we have changed and so now
as far as to decide whether this is a
valid change or not and yes this is a
valid change and it looks fantastic and
we want to use this as the new version
of the baseline so we're going to accept
this one
looking at this page here we like all of
the changes here as well and we can
accept that as well
and with all of that said we are pretty
far down in our coding and the testing
journey we've validated pretty much
everything about our application
we validated that the app renders
correctly and that the app looks as
expected
on web and mobile using our visual dom
to database tests also known as
end-to-end tests and we did it with the
following technologies there is still a
lot further to go and a lot more to test
however
this is all the time that we have today
and this is where we have to part ways
so thank you so much for tuning in today
to watch my tutorial
in summary we learned how to create a
simple react web app using create react
app we added component tests using react
testing library we shifted right by
adding visual tests using webdriverio
and screener and then we put it all into
a ci pipeline using github actions that
executes on push and pull requests
it's been my pleasure if you want to
learn more you can always reach out to
me at ultimateqva.com or my social
medias and i'd be happy to connect have
a wonderful day